can be boring at times but we look at
detail we don't we don't look at the
cardiovascular training
that should consent to you say that'll
come naturally as you get better speed
should increase in a natural way
so
when i was in iwama
you prayed for the hour
the clock on the air to go faster
because that was hard training this
floor is softer than the tatami
um
and being in japan he didn't explain a
lot he would just
demonstrate it say yokamen and they'd
attack you know attacking me through the
demonstration a couple of times and he'd
just go and sort of stand back
and you'd do it for 10 minutes non-stop
and it was linking hard training
and i
went there and this was he said tony if
you want your fifth down you've got to
come to obama this time
you've sort of put these pressure on me
because uh
on an earlier seminar somewhere in the
world
he said all my walmart
students out the front he said
demonstrating
and i stood back and he shouted at me
and goes honey
and afterwards he said don't ever do
that again
i said scentsy but i haven't been to
obama
he said you've traveled all around the
world to see me
you're only while i'm a student but he
then said
be at the obama dojo for your fifth dan
so when i went there i couldn't
understand why he wasn't explaining
everything
and then mars kessler who you might have
heard of he explained to me that um ah
that's where sense is so clever he knows
that the westerners wants
lots of questions
and lots of answers to those questions
so what he does is he switches hats
and he gives the westerners all the
information plus the techniques it gives
the japanese a demonstration because
they're a nation of copiers they can
copy really well and he don't it gives
him nothing as far as feedback goes
so i'd had without realizing i had the
best of both worlds
and um
i realized that it you don't really want
to go to walmart if you want to learn
because you just get beaten up there
you become very good but you know you're
going to need new hip replacements and
these replacements with the time you're
60 60.